هذا واظهرت مشاهدينا الهجمات الاخيره التي
شنتها داخل العمق الروسي حجم الخلافات بين
قائد فاجنر والقاده العسكريين الروس خلاف
ظهر على هامش معركه باخ مطحمه حينما انتقد
في حينها يبغيني بريجوجين قائد المجموعه
شبه العسكريه طبعا الروسيه انتقد وزير
الدفاع الروسي السرغي شيجو بسبب نقص
امدادهم بالذخيره هذا الخلاف ايضا اتسع
لاحقا لتصل اخر محطاته الى بلغرود اتهم
بريغوجين القاده العسكريين الروس بالتقصير
في الدفاع عن المدينه المتاخمه لاوكرانيا
والتي تعرضت كما تحدثنا لقصف وايضا هجمات
مكثفه على مدار ايام قال ان افعال الجيش
توحي برغبه في التنازل عن اراض في
بيلجارود بريجوجين اكد انه مستعد لارسال
وحداته للدفاع عن تلك المنطقه الروسيه
طبعا المتاخمه لاوكرانيا والتي كما ذكرنا
تعرضت في الايام الاخيره لقصف تعرضت ايضا
لهجمات مكثفه من الجانب الاوكراني بروجين
قال اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ما
يحدث هناك في بيلجرود حيث يتم الاستيلاء
على اراضي روسيه فهمنا من الواضح اننا
سنتدخل
اذا لم توقف وزاره الدفاع في المستقبل
القريب ما يحدث في منطقه بلغرود لان ما
يحصل هناك هو استلاء على اراضي الاتحاد
الروسي والمنطقه لاجل هذا اشدد على اننا
سنذهب الى القرود لحمايه شعبنا الروسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات